la unión europea rechazó los resultados
de las elecciones de belarús del pasado
9 de agosto
los líderes europeos aseguraron que los
comicios no fueron libres en el país y
condenaron la violencia policial
ejercida contra los manifestantes
opositores
no hay duda de que hubo violaciones
masivas de las reglas de las elecciones
las elecciones no fueron libres ni
justas y es por eso que el resultado de
los comicios no puede ser reconocido la
presión aumenta sobre mí que desde el 9
de agosto atraviesa jornadas de huelga
en general contra el gobierno algo que
ha hecho que las detenciones se
multipliquen en belarús y que la
candidata opositora sven de nati cano
osca ya se haya visto obligada a salir
del país desde su exilio en lituania
llamo para elecciones bajo supervisión
internacional mixta ocasión el señor
lukashenko ha perdido toda la
legitimidad a los ojos de nuestra nación
y del mundo
ante la situación lukashenko anunció que
reforzaría militarmente las fronteras
del país y que prestaría especial
atención a las fuerzas de la otan
[Aplausos]
si alguien piensa que el poder está
fallando y tambaleándose está equivocado
ese poder final
en quien confiar así que no vacilaremos
seguiremos con nuestro camino como es
debido
sobre los turbios o los que hoy están
conspirando contra nosotros recibirán un
serio rechazo sustituto para los
interiores de por alexander lukashenko
llevan el poder en belarús desde 1994 y
aunque la oposición ha conseguido
desafiar su poder las autoridades
electorales anunciaron que lukashenko
tomará juramento dentro de dos meses